carly helped us uh with a lot of the
infrastructure of lobby three which is
very there's exciting stuff we're doing
a um kind of blockchain 101 tutorial for
congressional staffers and
the representatives themselves and
lobbyists so they can actually learn
what it is like we're getting like our
treasury's built up we're going to have
some funds and voting um go ahead what i
was going to say on that right like
regardless of how you feel about
blockchain or crypto or nfts and i know
there's a lot of negative impressions
around that yeah and this is not a
crypto podcast so those of you who have
don't change the channel yet we're
getting there yeah yeah yeah no no for
sure but what i was going to say about
that is like regardless of those
impressions i think
this technology is going to be with us
in sort of fundamental ways even when
the when the weird overpriced jpegs die
off and and the hype is gone this tech
will be here and i think we we know
the the problem with having a very
technologically illiterate congress and
i think we've seen that play out in
social media and in a variety of other
ways so i think we can all agree like
just the importance of making sure that
our
representatives are just better versed
in technology right and hopefully one of
things lobby three can do is just help
us to leapfrog some of the stages where
which is like a completely kind of
illiterate body of representatives right
that we saw with like you know they
learn it from you know with a political
spin they learn it um from the media or
donors or others right or this becomes a
political football and becomes
polarizing more than it is so that's
that's the goal and it's exciting
[Music]
[Music]
this week on forward the one and only
crypto carly riley is back if you
remember she would be on here all the
time this past summer she's back now we
break apart the crypto bro narrative is
there truth to that what's true and
what's not we also talk about the boys
and men crisis from a female perspective
and what's going on in ukraine with
russia
breaking that down a little bit don't
miss it tune in to forward right now
[Music]
welcome back to the forward podcast with
andrew yang i'm your host andrew yang
joined by my colleague zach grauman
go bills i love josh allen nailed it
living the dream uh
but seriously welcome back as you can
tell
andrew's not here andrew's on vacation
he doesn't take a vacation very often
the only time he really takes a vacay is
when evelyn makes him do something with
the kids so he's doing something with
the kids which is
uh running around disney world today oh
oh yeah i'm very very keen on getting
some like yang in uh i'll see your hats
you know what i'm saying oh yeah yeah oh
i guess the kids would be cute but him
would just be kind of hilarious
but we're joined by carly riley who many
of you
have become familiar with during a
period where andrew was running for
mayor
we ran this show together yeah carly has
since left us
but welcome back to the show yeah
appreciate it it feels like a coming
home a homecoming
so today's show should be pretty fun uh
even though we are andrew yang less but
we've got brought the great carly riley
back and we're coming at you live from
south by southwest in austin texas
big shout out out the gate to emergent
order who is the production company that
is hosting us in their very cool studio
very it's frankly cooler than ours and
bigger and better air conditioned and
all the good things
um and also a shout out to the podcast
dad saves america
who is kind of the flagship show out of
the studio and very cool trying to get
andrew on there too but that's always a
moving target giving his schedule anyway
carly welcome back thank you glad you're
here appreciate being here so i want to
talk about the elephant in the room very
important thing you've left us
for your own show
um that seems to be doing well i'm not
gonna say doing better than us but
you know we could tell that later in in
within my own niche world
i don't know how to say it yeah i mean
you're a crypto currency celebrity so
tell us about why you left not why you
left us but yeah a little bit why you
left us but what you're up to what's
going on sure well you know love yang
speaks was very grateful to uh get my
podcasting start cut my podcasting teeth
so to speak on the yang speaks channel
really
just out of necessity yang you mentioned
earlier yang was running for mayor so
you were like hey come come help co-host
with me we kind of need a second person
and
got bit by the podcasting bug i guess
actually you know it's a it's a
yang speaks played a role in my where i
am today in that you and i interviewed
ryan sean adams yeah back in the very
beginning of last year very smart guy
very good very smart ryan is the
co-founder of bank list which is a
crypto media network he co-founded it
with david hoffman and we interviewed
him
that i'd sort of been going down the
rabbit hole a little bit prior but like
crypto rabbit hole crypto rabbit hole
but ryan definitely kicked it off that
much further went like deep down and of
course as as people in the space
describe like you just get sucked into
this world of web 3 and can't look away
and so that started happening and then
ryan approached me and he was like hey
um would you want to come do your own
podcast through bankless
and
that is what i have been doing now for
the last several months in addition to i
work a job with blockblock who's an
awesome startup so your
your what's your show called oh my show
is called
you take credit for it but you get no
credit drum roll please overpriced jpegs
which is what nfts are so okay
overpriced jpegs yeah i mean it's
somewhat self-explanatory overpriced
jpegs being there are a lot of nfts in
the world today that are uh
quite literally just like overpriced
jpegs and then it's also a
tongue-in-cheek reference to the fact
that like outsiders to the space think
that all nfts are overpriced jpegs when
in reality there's a lot of really
interesting deep tech happening that is
uh justifies call it
the costs okay so let me say a couple of
days i say i work on web3 have i like
properly introduced myself to this at
all i feel like i don't know the yang
speaks audience anymore actually
and we're clear that you're in web 3.
and this is actually my point so i i
made a kind of a mental list of um how
you can tell someone
is working in crypto they'll tell you
and um so number one right
number one they tell you they work in
crypto it's like talking to a vegan um
or someone who does crossfit um it's
probably the same um
do you agree with that
yeah except i actually
yes but i
really don't like saying i work in it
like you know you tell you you say
you're in media uber driver i say work
at a startup or a tech startup okay like
you know i because we are at a place
where now everybody like has a
perception of what that is and has an
opinion and sometimes it's negative or
positive and then or they ask you to
explain it and i'm like man i'm just
trying to get from point a to point b
and let's
listen to a podcast okay so it's sort of
like working on the the presidential
campaign oh yeah when you say you work
in politics you work for a candidate you
work for andrew yang it like opens up a
whole can of worms i keep ending up in
these industries that are like can of
worm industries where it's not just like
i work on insurance and nobody wants to
bother you anymore yeah so i i'm now i
went from one industry where i had to
pretend i did something else to another
industry where i sort of pretended
that's true if i ever had time to go to
a cocktail party or social gathering on
the presidential campaign people asked
what i would do and i would say
i'm a consultant yeah
yeah or i work in i work in policy that
was the other way yeah because people
like that type of policy oh boring
behind the scenes
reform stuff yeah you just you're just
not worth what do you do yeah um yeah
okay so number one
uh
they tell you they tell you
number two they use the phrase in the
space i think this is unique to me no
it's not it's totally not um i've now
been to been dragged to enough web3
events that they use the phrase in the
space a lot and it'll be phrases like oh
he's really well known in the space like
everybody in the space thinks it's a big
deal or
well if you're in the space
but so why is that weird
and i don't know there's lots of spaces
and i don't think people use that phrase
well so here's what i will say this
feels like a it feels like an out crowd
in crowd phrases here's what i think it
is right you have
you do have your own sort of like
ecosystem of web3 yeah
it's my entire twitter feed is web3
right like it's it's a very
all-encompassing kind of an ecosystem
and so we have our own
celebrities within web3 we have our own
influencers within web3 we have our own
builders and you start to get to know
all these characters and it is hard to
kind of you either say in web 3 or in
the space because especially you and i
have been working on a web 3 project
together like it's important to be able
to say hey you should you should talk to
this person because they're they matter
in the space like and i that's not true
of other
like i don't know the world of
cosmetics is very very yeah yeah like it
doesn't feel like you have that same
sort of insularity and like work this
cultish thing happening
um okay so i don't know it just is a
helpful
it's helpful in conversation
and then the third one is you have a
profile picture of yeah like board ape's
too obvious but but it's usually
something
that i don't recognize like a non-human
it's a little doodle of some sort yeah
um what's your pfp profile it's just you
so you don't work in this space no
i think because you don't yeah you don't
get it this has actually been a very
intentional thing on my part which is
that i think
part of
the role i hope i can
sort of fill is to a little bit have a
foot in
in both worlds i think
i
love web3 i think i can speak web 3 and
blockchain and it's my profession now
and i absolutely love it but i also
think i can i can still kind of relate
it to or or you know the normies
yeah and i think that's what you call us
yeah
there it is i think one fourth right
there refer to others not in the space
as normie
and i i'm part normie and i think
that uh yeah i think it's helpful to
have representatives from from the space
uh who don't necessarily like have the
the the weird pfp right that maybe feel
more approachable to somebody so i've
i've really intentionally kept my
identity my identity and it's just my
own headshot cryptocarly so of so carly
did i mean look the show's going well
it's interesting especially if you're
in the space
it's 2022 and you like to personalize
just about everything in your life and
yet you drink the same cup of coffee
every morning even though it's gotten a
little bit stale you don't know where
it's sourced why buy the same old same
old instead get a coffee that you know
you're going to love because it's made
for you take the coffee quiz to get
started
trade coffee
will source from america's best
independent roasters ethically so it'll
taste great and you'll feel great about
it they guarantee you'll love your first
bank or they will replace it for free
trade has been featured by the new york
times wired gq and has delivered over 5
million bags of coffee why not to you
for our listeners right now trade coffee
is offering a total of twenty dollars
off your first three bags when you go to
drinktrade.com
yang to get started take their quiz at
drinktrade.com
yang and start your journey to your
perfect cup that's drinktrade.com yang
for 20 off your first three bags
[Music]
carly helped us uh with a lot of the
infrastructure of lobby 3 which is
very there's exciting stuff we're doing
a
kind of blockchain 101 tutorial for
congressional staffers and
the representatives themselves and
lobbyists so they can actually learn
what it is like we're getting like our
treasury's built up we're going to have
some funds and voting um go ahead what i
was going to say on that right like
regardless of how you feel about call
blockchain or crypto or nfts and i know
there's a lot of negative impressions
around that yeah and this is not a
crypto podcast so those of you who have
don't change the channel yet we're
getting there yeah yeah yeah no no for
sure but but what i was going to say
about that is like regardless of those
impressions i think
this technology is going to be with us
in sort of fundamental ways even when
the when the weird overpriced jpegs die
off and and the hype is gone this tech
will be here and i think we we know
the the problem with having a very
technologically illiterate congress and
i think we've seen that play out in
social media and in a variety of other
ways so
i think we can all agree like just the
importance of making sure that our
representatives are just better versed
in technology right and hopefully one of
things lobby three can do is just help
us to leapfrog some of the stages where
we're just like a completely kind of
illiterate
body of representatives right that we
saw with like you know they learn it
from you know with a political spin they
learn it um from the media or
donors or others right or this becomes a
political football and becomes
polarizing more than it is so that's
that's the goal and it's exciting um
so tell us
you know one of the things i um you've
been doing a lot
to
kind of broaden the lens of
i think the web 3 space specifically
outside the us and you've been traveling
so tell us like what your your kind of
vision for this is and um
especially for folks on this pod who
probably are not
i mean some are but probably are not
what's called web three native or i
guess in this space is the phrase you
know
i really i do feel like a weird person
like crawling out of a hole right now
talking to this audience because i now
have my own podcast and i talk to people
who are who are very in the space and so
i'm like
no no no no i'm just i'm struggling to
orient i i like can't get it i don't
know so i apologize if this is
too in-depth or too not in depth
whatever but i think i sort of have this
mantra for this year for the podcast
that i'm doing uh where it's like nfts
beyond pfps so pfp's standing for
profile pictures that's what you were
describing earlier it's the apes it's
like all these all these kind of jpeg
images that we now associate with nfts
that feel often times just like really
overpriced and absurd and weird yeah um
and so really trying to highlight and
have conversations on my show that
that go deeper than that um
that look more the underlying technology
explain why it's interesting i think the
other problem we face right now is
we're this technology is so so new and
we're still in these very like emergent
stages of it and but because there's so
much money being generated around it
the outside world kind of looks at it
like it's a fully baked technology
because it's getting a lot of media
coverage so they assess it like it's
fully baked and like this is absurd but
they really need to be looking at it as
like the early early stages of something
that's evolving right i've given this
analogy to you and i will get to the
travel piece of this but like
you know in the very early
the first car that was ever invented in
like the 1800s
had a top speed of like 11 miles per
hour and then 20 years later you had the
model t come out and it could go i think
a top speed of 45 miles per hour
a really good horse at a sprint can go
55 miles per hour so you can imagine all
these people when the car was first
being invented being like what the hell
is the point of this thing right like
it's slower than a horse it's messing up
the cobblestone streets and we're
further along than that in blockchain
there are some real legitimate amazing
uses for blockchain that make things
more efficient et cetera et cetera but
but there's a certain level of word
there with blockchain right now which is
like we're still slower than the horse
sometimes so people look at it and
they're like what this solves nothing
like what is this doing right and it's
like well the infrastructure is being
built so that in 30 years or 10 years or
whatever
these systems are way more efficient and
way better than what had come previously
and enable all sorts of new things that
we can't even fully imagine yet you
couldn't have imagined everything that
came from the automobile industry when
in 1900 um
and so i i
really trying to spell that out for
folks and then
having conversations that maybe give a
glimpse to what that future might look
like beyond just again here's my profile
picture on twitter so that's what i'm
trying to do with the show and uh well
the stereotype on crypto which i think
you're working to break um
just by doing cool things but
it's
frankly it's guys that look and maybe
sound like me
maybe a little bro
and who are straight white dudes
getting rich saying take this [ __ ] to
the moon and they use phrases like wag
me and
doge and gm and other i don't know so
what um but you've you've had a lot of
folks that are not
even close to that mold in the slightest
like what um what are you seeing what
needs to be highlighted more what are
your thoughts there for sure uh i think
yeah it's sort of like white and asian
crypto bros is sort of like a uh
stereotype um so i was just in puerto
rico for example and
we were both there we were there with
yang and as part of that trip i ended up
interviewing there's a there's a really
blossoming nft crypto scene happening in
puerto rico right and there's an
interesting dynamic happening because
you have something called ax60 which is
a law that was put in place in puerto
rico that gives a tremendous like
capital gains tax incentive
incentives to
newcomers who move to the island
basically you if you take up residency
in puerto rico from outside of puerto
rico you don't have to pay capital gains
taxes of course that's attracted a ton
of crypto bros and but crypto people to
the island and that's sort of been the
narrative around puerto rico is like
crypto bros on the island you know these
crypto colonizers right like that's been
sort of but behind that is actually a
burgeoning group of artists i mean
puerto rico is an incredibly artistic
island you've got tremendous artistic
talent the muralists like there's all
the street art
it has several really top-notch
technical institutes so you actually
have some really strong engineering
talent coming out of puerto rico and
that usually end up leaving puerto rico
for
opportunities elsewhere
um and you have this really rebellious
spirit
because of its dynamic to the u.s
because of their own issues with
corruption they face with the government
and so you have
you know native puerto ricans who are
doing a lot when it comes to nfts who
are sort of getting erased in this
narrative like crypto colonizers so i
went and talked to a bunch of people
artists who were doing really
interesting innovative things with with
um nfts and with blockchain technology
women doing awesome art you know all of
that stuff is is happening and right i
think
it's it's you know it's highlighted now
i'm not saying there isn't a shortage of
women or or a narrative yeah but but you
know and i'm sort of a fan of like
kind of just lead by example uh
hopefully
my just being a woman and presence in
the space like i'm not tr i'm not i'm
not leading with that right my womanness
like i host a podcast i actually love
this stuff i just do the podcast
my audience does skew more female than
for example bankless's audience which um
is the network i do it through i think
probably in part because i'm a woman and
people like you know gravitating towards
people who who they feel a little bit
more represented by but
um i'm just kind of trying to do it and
not um good not like
you know not market it intentionally as
a woman thing or not i think that's that
can be appealing to some people and
that's yeah that's like the the
challenge where it's you know
how do you get more women in in the
space if you will like well
the women that are there do bad ass
things and other women are like that's
cool right um i sometimes do worries
there's so many there is such a
narrative like there aren't enough women
in web 3. and it's not again it's not
that there isn't a problem with that but
i do sometimes worry that messaging
may turn off sort of like you know if
you're a woman and you're like hearing
like there's no women here like
it kind of doesn't make you necessarily
want to go do it right i almost
sometimes worry there's like a counter
productivity to that narrative um
as opposed to me just being like hey i'm
here i love it i feel very welcome i
know a bunch of other women who feel the
same way right
which is a very real narrative as well
and almost to me is more compelling than
to get women in the space than
highlighting the actual the lack of it
yeah i think it's helpful to have both
right you have people like eva longoria
and reese witherspoon like some really
high profile female celebrities who are
drawing attention to it and i think
if it's when it's them it can be really
helpful um
but
yeah i just think there's different ways
to approach the like how do we make a
space more diverse
and i think so having been here at south
by and going to number the tech
events or
meeting some of the tech folks i mean
the diverse it is a pretty diverse and
interesting crowd right i said like you
know never except yeah some there's some
truth in these narratives that come out
in the media but they're not always
grounded in anecdotal reality or what a
lot of people's lived experiences are um
speaking of being on the ground uh
you'll notice our p terry's cups which
uh apparently we are not sponsored by
them um so we're open to it but we're
open we love your burgers and fries so
we're very apparently the in and out of
austin texas um
though in and out is also here in austin
texas oh yeah so it's a bit and i've had
this is pathetic of me but i've had in
and out yesterday and this today peter
is today let's celebrate that don't
celebrate that yes just i don't just
recommend eating two double burgers uh
with in the same 24 hour span but here
we are um
and i would say
i don't know it's definitely up for
debate i mean now it's probably better
given it's like national reach and
success outside of one city but p terry
is very very good
very good i enjoyed it
[Music]
so
what i thought we'd do with carly is get
some
andrew and i've been talking about a
number of different different things on
this podcast and there have been a few
times i'm like i wonder what carly
thinks about this and i'll been able to
talk to her obviously off the record but
wanted to get the opportunity to give
her a little rapid fire and have some
fun
um which you may hate me for because i
haven't really prepared you for all this
i'm like nervous well mostly because i
just like i already see the comments
being like why the [ __ ] are we getting
this like random girl sorry i cursed but
random girl's opinion on x y or z but
you know what because here right because
you're here and um
i think you're a smart thoughtful human
and it's one of the things we want this
show is is trying to put
smart thoughtful people um to talk about
the issues of the day because frankly
that's tough to find that's sad it's
really sad but it's reality and i think
a lot that's a lot of the feedback i get
well here's here's the good news here's
what you will get from me like my
uh call it media diet is so weird at
this point again mostly because like
twitter which is where i historically
have gotten news is like now all crypto
stuff you're getting a very interesting
uh perspective you're you're not going
to get somebody who's reading your
typical sources good
um so let's so a couple things so one
the big one is andrew and i've been
talking a lot about boys and men um and
the boys men crisis and
we talked a lot about it but the biggest
at least my biggest takeaway and andrew
doesn't say it as
i mean with as much conviction the way i
say it and so he'd probably maybe pick a
different major takeaway but my big
takeaway is that um
the failure and the crisis that boys and
men are having right now and when men
disintegrate it hurts women so if you
want to be a strong champion of women
counter-intuitively
you may need to start with focusing on
boys and men and keeping men strong and
whole which obviously is ridiculous
and sounds like a men's right activist
to be like hey you want to focus on
women like start with the guys but the
reality like the numbers are true right
and um
weak men
and broken men um either make society
worse which ends up hurting women and
girls or proactively hurt women and
girls so thoughts on this because here
we are two dudes talking about this but
i know you to be
um
very feminist and one of the reasons you
joined the andrew yang campaign was
because you told me universal basic
income can be universally the best thing
we could do for women to empower women
internationally so and all over the
world right so thoughts on the boy
crisis yeah uh
so i i totally agree i mean you know i
think obviously we don't want to treat
it as an either or situation i think you
know in some ways the the boy crisis
you know it stems out of maybe too much
of a focus solely on on the crisis of
women i mean i i strongly say that so
like you don't want to reverse this and
now just like go 100 and like only deal
with the suffering
boys go back and swing the pendulum back
of course
it's called the 60s 70s right yeah so i
think um i think it's but i totally
agree and i think the reason that
men
not come first but you're as you're sort
of phrasing like that is the physical
dominance piece and it's not across the
board you obviously have lots of you
know super physically strong women but
like obviously on the whole men are
physically dominant over women um
and that's
that's at the heart of this whole thing
the reason
well the reason you have to care about
men and to some extent need to even
think about it
as like a
critically important piece of the women
issue is that right because the second a
woman is raped or assaulted or or abused
you know
that's a light that has a lifetime
impact on somebody you know and i i
hesitate obviously you can go on and do
incredible things as a woman dealing
with that but it's just an extra layer
of baggage that you have to deal with
and carry with you and fight through
um
and so
because of that of course we need to
focus on the health of men and boys
because
if they're hurting they you know hurt
people hurt people you know as a girl
you learn that like bullying her
girlfriend girls right like bullying in
seventh grade is like that but you know
it's true across the board and so as
long as um
weak men will hurt women right um how
can um
men on this team
talk about it without coming off
like an ass
that's actually that's the root of most
of things i'm trying to talk about i'm
just trying to solve problems without
sounding like an ass um
and that and the problem with solving
problems is you have to make a judgment
there's a hierarchy there you have to
make a decision um and decisions are
never perfect and
usually the best ones are utilitarian
like great is good for the greatest
number right um
so that's a challenge for everybody but
like personally like is there a way
things guys
myself or andrew um trying to champion
this
can do better can talk about it better
not to put i'm putting you on the spot
but um
because i again didn't prepare carly for
this
i mean you know
i'm sort of a weird person to ask about
this because
i agree with you guys and so i when i
when i i haven't admittedly i have not
listened to like the main podcast
episode you did about this that's okay
um but i
i agree with you and i do tend to think
that the criticism that gets levied at
these kinds of arguments when they're
being made in the way that like i've
heard you make them
usually don't feel like they're engaging
with the argument in good faith right
they're sort of they're extrapolating
hearing what you're saying and they're
extrapolating a whole bunch of other
opinions from that
things that we do in politics in general
right now like if you express an opinion
that leaves liens call it left or is
left
the the right will extrapolate a whole
bunch of things about what that means
you must also believe you're also and
then you do the reverse right if you
have an opinion that leans right the
left will then take that and extrapolate
that means you must believe all these
other xyz things about this so i think
when you start to get into talking about
you know a crisis of boys and men
there's all these extrapolations that
get made which you know that means you
want to conform to very traditional
gender roles like you know you it means
you must think that men are made to go
out and work and be strong and women
should stay home like things that are
not at all what you guys are saying so i
think part of it is
um
the lead by example piece which is
you know
highlighting areas where um i don't know
i'm like struggling to even say that
like to really think about it
it's not on you to find the answer i'm
just more curious um again trying not to
be an [ __ ] and trying to engage in
good faith which is something you do
naturally given who you are but if
there's ways to um
i don't like turning off the left
because um i generally align with well
like liz plank is you know
yours yeah and as a friend who i think
is doing uh obviously is is very much
coming from the left and as a woman it's
sort of she's in a different position
than you are as like a very like certain
looking kind of dude um but she
she obviously does a good job talking
about the masculinity crisis no i think
she leans more on the side of like we
need to make sure that boys can be
sensitive and feel emotional and she
looks at like you know when uh babies if
you like babies like you know baby boys
are
as as if not more emotive than like baby
girls are and that you know there's a
certain level of like acculturating that
out of people um
and
you know i think there's a
i know i think you give some really
specific examples even that come from
your dad right of like
you know
when you decide what responsibilities
are in a relationship right like you
live up to that right like if you were
taking out the trash right and then your
wife is nagging you eight times like
about taking that trash like oh she's
such a nag and it's like well did you
take out the trash like did you do your
job or
husband yeah as a supporter
you know like this goes across both ways
and i think
you know that's a really good example of
like what it means to be a strong man in
your opinion that is like obviously not
toxic that's a good so one like the
actual story is my dad would say when he
does a lot of his men's ministry he
would have guys come in and they'd say
i know you want me to be like
treat my wife like like the bible and my
dad's christian and then um i grew up in
the christian home and you know one of
the things the bible says is like
love your wife like christ loved the
church like kind of the ethos of it and
christ died for the church in the bible
so it's like so it's literally like what
you should you know
do everything you know essentially die
for your wife in like the hypothetical
sense but you should it should be number
one to you and
so that he'd have guys come in the men's
ministry and they're like look i know
i'm supposed to you know love my wife
and be this but she just nags me all the
time and he'd be like well what is she
nagging about it's like well i gotta
make the bed or vacuum this or take out
the trash she's like well flip that on
your head man on its head
if you believe it's your job to provide
for your wife and keep her safe and keep
her loving fulfilled and happy
then this is your job man so it's not
her job to take out the trash she's
reminding you to do your damn job and so
like flipping that mindset is like the
mail the provider which isn't toxic or
yeah i was gonna say i mean even you
saying that like if you believe the
man's role is like to provide for the
wife i think that's where you start to
get this bristling on the part of the
left of like oh that sounds like though
like so then what does that mean her job
is if it's his job to provide for her
that sounds very like this traditional
gender role thing where like you have to
go out and provide and and i have to
stay at home and whatever and that
becomes my job right and i think it's a
it's a
i think that the core of what you're
saying is more like whatever two people
right whatever gender whatever
relationship it is right like decide the
kind of respective roles are it's about
consistently showing up for your side of
the role right like i think it'll be i
want to have kids and i very much want
to work and you know i'm like
want my husband to be very involved in
the kids right and so if that that then
for him it's like whatever the
responsibility is around helping to
raise those children or and that's why
the trash example or cleaning up is good
because that's usually the woman's role
like
it's about like okay we all are gonna
have days where we don't wanna do
certain things but part of being in a
relationship and being a strong adult
and like therefore strong man is like
doing whatever your end of the bargain
is
um and i think that can that that end of
the bargain doesn't have to be what is
traditionally just make the money right
it's like you know or be the
disciplinarian yeah it's like being a a
man is is fulfilling whatever your your
side of that bargain and i don't think
the bible is always the best in terms of
uh like some of the when the church has
been responsible for a lot of these
traditional gender roles that i think
gone to certain extremes or even taken
out of context or taken literally can be
awful right
but
much of the
most of the worst ones are in the old
testament i mean for bible context the
new testament is like how we should do
things going forward and then so the new
testament has a little bit of a
more positive ethos of it um and
there's a you know one of the things
that uh that christ talked about was uh
being equally yoked in a marriage and
that's like sort of to me you know
really that could be a relationship or
anything but having like equally yolked
or yin and yang like that can be
anything
it doesn't have to be in a traditional
format as long as it's balanced right
when you and i debate this because i
feel like you can take the best parts of
any book it feels like a little bit the
bible stuff is just like taking the best
parts of the bible it's like you take
the best parts
of the keys it just feels like good
lessons
but there's some books in the bible
maybe one of them where it's like they
have some pretty some black and white
stuff and it feels like oh i'm gonna
take the stuff i like and not the other
stuff i like some of it's hard right but
um i agree with you like trying to
there's some verse in the bible
that's probably not
one we want to celebrate um
anyway there's not a religious podcast
y'all um but i do think religion in
context of everything is always is
always helpful
[Music]
last thing i want to ask you about carly
and then maybe on more of a positive
note um
ukraine
this is where the youtube commenters are
like why the [ __ ] why should that be
great um because why not i'm talking
about you great well i just wanna
curious your thoughts we haven't talked
about it we've been talking about it a
lot and um yeah of course it's like
what's in the news our last conversation
about how ukraine put a lot of things in
perspective on uh
you know i've been called on twitter
like anyone who gets a certain size on
twitter it gets called awful things like
the root of all evil or whatever the
hell you're called and then you're
looking at russia and you're like well i
mean maybe i'm not the root of all
perhaps
what are your thoughts on what's going
on how we're digesting it
it's like just like shocking uh and
obviously tragic and
it does feel like i i'm so curious
about putin's thinking because it does
feel like he must have just
categorically underestimated the resolve
of the ukrainian people and i and i
think the unanim like unanimity of the
west's response i mean you know i find
it like i was saying this i think the
other day with somebody like
flabbergasting that switzerland like is
not neutral you know like they got they
got um switzerland who was neutral in
world war ii switzerland against the
nazis
neutral to the nazis and has now you
know right take a stand so that's
i think very interesting um
you know i uh
it's tragic i heard so i listen to the
all-in podcast i'm a big fan of that i
bet there's i bet there's a good deal of
overall they don't sponsor us but
they're a fun pod yeah i'm sure there's
a i think david sacks and andrew are
doing a podcast sometime soon
well and saks is is very smart again
agree or disagree where he kind of lies
politically because i think he's more of
the right wing of that group but like a
super sharp guy and anything he actually
talked about this he was like
you know he's pretty isolationist like
he's like absolutely under no
circumstances i think largely speaking
i'm not trying to put more than is not
but like we should not get ourselves
militarily involved in ukraine um
and
they were doing sort of an interesting
look at
after
[Music]
or right before putin invaded crimea
um
the sort of question around ukraine
joining nato was like bubbling to the
surface again and i don't know exactly
what precipitated the whole thing right
but essentially you had putin's made it
very very clear that he does not that he
cannot stomach having ukraine or uh join
nato because then he's surrounded
whatever
um so
uh anthony lincoln he came out and quite
forcefully sort of made a statement
saying that nato's doors were open like
basically directly rebuffing putin and
saying like we will very much keep the
option of ukraine joining nato a
possibility right
and
so all in was making this argument that
i just think is interesting and people
may agree with it or not i don't even
know how i feel about it but like
basically that was a such a
miscalculation because that has put us
in a position now where
we don't know is putin invading ukraine
simply on this question of nato and like
you know he's he's really just doing it
to uh
keep ukraine from joining nato which i
think he can get a lot more sympathy
from his own people and elsewise
or is there a grand or kind of hitlerian
ambition here right like is this a
madman now who really wants to like you
know take over europe now i've had
people make the point like he
wouldn't be able to take over europe but
like whatever it is it does have nukes
but you know but he's not you know that
becomes a totally you know then it is
just the mutually assured destruction
thing so that was just an interesting
argument of like looking back at what
our foreign policy has been and was that
a misstep should we have categorically
said no we won't let ukraine a to nato
to avoid a situation like this
um
you know i don't know where it falls but
i just i hadn't really somebody heard
somebody lay that out and i think it's
interesting so
the best situation i think for the u.s
appears to be
ukraine holds
and we help from outside looking in the
way we all know we're doing the way the
you know the
un and eu and essentially are helping
and all these other countries in their
own way
and then you know to andrew's point
before is that russia declares its own
victory but it's really a loss and then
this all kind of goes away and the u.s
didn't have to do anything i think
that's an important point is like we
have to give an exit path to putin
because he's so prideful and he's such
an ego and so it's sort of like how
we as the west can help to facilitate
like we i believe we should like
whatever sort of saving face mechanism
he needs to ideally be able to leave
ukraine and but feel like his his face
has been saved uh which is rough um but
we're going to so the other thing that
some i'm curious your thoughts about it
maybe ties of the boys and men crisis
i've come up before is that so when we
have these wars boys
no but no boon is a model of a boy and a
man of grace
um but no but he has his own definition
of masculinity and feels a purpose like
there are things there that i mean he's
obviously got a toxic masculinity in a
in a human form
right i i don't know that we can debate
that all day i'm not saying he's not a
toxic masculinity my point is like he
did he didn't fall without a purpose and
then grab on down these youtube rabbit
holes and and feeling or depressed
anxiety and that sort of thing he's been
clearly like
has a [ __ ] up purpose hasn't been
living that in a certain you know what
i'm saying i think it's a different type
of well but it's a very very prideful
kind of like you know nationalism feels
like a very masculine thing it's like
this but that has that's not the type of
men we've been talking about you know
what i'm saying um well maybe that's
that would help you with the left if you
did certainly talk about those kinds of
because that's that is very much a
crisis as well right and those are very
much the kind of men who are hurting
women and so i think you know as you're
looking for yeah you're making a good
point i'm just wondering
you know i'm thinking about like
what i'm talking about like damaged men
you know you've and voice that you see
the damage i'm talking about with a guy
who becomes a school shooter i don't
think it's the same type of damage you
talk about no but it it there's a
similar it's a similar just toxic you
just went
he's shooting up an entire [ __ ]
country this kind of brings me back to
maybe the first thing when you talk
about boys men where
there's a reason russia has not had
success invading ukraine and it's
because the ukraine army feels like they
have something to fight for
um
but
you know who's fighting in these wars
right it's young men we're talking
probably 18 to 35 right probably younger
than that um you probably have some 16
year olds and 15 year olds and carry a
gun
squeeze in there and then probably you
know 30 is probably the average like
median if you will on the higher end
um
do you think this generation's like
fundamentally less violent or less
purposeful in that existential like this
is worth fighting and dying over
ukrainian
i mean i think if you look at the united
states when you look at a lot of other
countries when it came what it came push
comes to shove to bury arms like i feel
like our threshold for war and that type
of like where i'm gonna take a gun and
fight
is a lot higher um and you're seeing on
the russian side right now they're like
dude we don't like many of them like we
don't care we thought we're gonna win
we're not oops shrug right i mean at
least as the rumors coming out yeah and
i think this is like you know this is
again another all-in podcast point like
the fog of war like we have no idea
that's right like we are being
propagandized so much of the stuff that
we're seeing is ukrainian propaganda
they're doing very well and i don't
blame them for that but like we have
it's it's we're in it's a war zone like
we can't trust if you learn anything um
if we learned anything from the campaign
is that most people on the outside have
no idea what's going on behind the
scenes and that's not even fault just
the reality is i learned that ubs too
like people see what the brand of ubs
was when i was working and like inside
was like way more complicated than that
and just we're not gonna go public on
anybody's on the team that's that so
there's definitely that that piece um
which is why you know again we're not
experts but i always think curious to
get a rational person's thoughts on this
type of thing
[Music]
well let me turn it on you zach we
talked about sort of my projects at the
start of this uh and not to make this
like a show episode but you had a big
announcement i don't believe you have
mentioned it on this podcast
that came out oh what do you mean
since the book came out i thought you
said the first podcast the book oh we
talked about it in the last episode a
bit oh i asked you if this was the first
episode to come out since the book
yes but we but the book was launched
essentially on the episode so since then
got it okay well
well no i mean i guess just basically
like you know i sort of was uh was there
during the behind-the-scenes writing of
it you put so much into this and like
i've you know read it probably not its
most recent draft but i've read earlier
drafts it's really funny i think people
are really going to like it and i'm not
funny so that's no no you're funny
though you've got you're a funny writer
once once no i can write funny because
you can edit it and take out the bad
jokes because like about like 100 i'm
joking is there like a story in the book
that you're most excited for people to
see
more like a takeaway more like a lesson
but i kind of want to hear you
there's two two things there's a bunch
of lessons i want people to take away we
should probably dive in i will dive in
with them with andrew for those who
don't like to read we'll give you the
sparkle version on this podcast but i'll
say a couple things one is
i really want people to understand the
like like how much of a long shot it was
and i like the first chapter opens with
like a detailed description of our first
terrible
andrew yang political event where
it's like a shitty yang banner 10 people
show up
we've we got like stella beers
and tostitos hint of lime chips and we
forgot to buy napkins and they're on
like amazon folding tables and people
have to like take the napkins off the
paper towel like take
take the paper towels off the bounty
roll sort of thing and it's a disaster
and we're like taking pictures make the
crowds look bigger it's not good two
then
how big it got where it's like almost 10
000 people in macarthur park in la with
like literal
sparks flying and that kind of technique
so that ride is like point of it um and
that which is fundamentally i think
funny um and fun and then
i think um
the most exciting story to me is the um
i call it too much of it
but like the comeback to me between like
the first miami debate where andrew was
really sick and well don't get you're
giving too much away there is a story oh
we've talked about this though
there was a first debate and if you
don't remember it
read the book okay and then there was a
second and then there was a second base
and if you don't know what happened to
me read the book and then stuff happened
in between come on man i don't like i
think you have to tell more about story
making exciting that's that's the story
and i think
a lot of it was a lot what we did on the
process to stand out and i think a
number of things not everything of
course but a number of things we did
would help anyone
compete in the attention economy as a
long shot or an outsider so i hope the
book like can stand the test of time
that's my hope um but anyway it's gonna
be fun i think the end game's gonna love
it so i um
i'm an author now it's been weird been
very weird very cool i'm sure we'll get
your crypto book in the future carl and
then we can have you back on here to
teach the audience about what it's like
to be in a space yeah uh anyway cool i
have to go to a call that's our show
thanks for having me that's our show
next week we might have andrew yang back
on his own podcast unclear tune in next
week we'll see you monday love you guys
[Music]
you